Thank you, Pajoga. Jerusalem Post.
Four-day pride festival to be held at
Dead Sea, largest in history of Middle
East.
April 19, 2026. Israel is set to host
the Middle East's largest ever LGBT
festival.
Dead Sea, where we found the Dead Sea
Scrolls, in June 2026.
The new festival, Prideland, intends to
transform the middle of the Judean
desert into a colorful pride city from
June 1st to June 4th.
But this is God's holy land. These are
God's holy people.
You're telling me
this was God's will
for the Jews to come back to Israel and
do to Jerusalem what their ancestors
did, which resulted in the destruction
of Jerusalem?
That's what you're telling me?
When Leviticus chapter 18, Leviticus
chapter 20 warned that if his people
did the sins of the nations, which
resulted in God destroying them, he
would destroy them and throw them out of
the land.
Leviticus chapter 18, Leviticus 20.
And here, they're back in the land
holding the largest
parade of homosexuals,
lesbians, transgendered,
right? People.
Right? And among them, they're going to
be
s.
Among them,
the largest in Middle East history.
And they're going to celebrate this for
4 days with the approval of Netanyahu's
government.
>> [sighs and gasps]
>> Netanyahu's government.
And they're God's people, huh?
They're God's people.
The event intends to create an
experience broader than parties or
performances, instead aiming for a space
that is alive 24 hours a day. So, 24
hours a day for 4 days, right?
On that land by the Dead Sea, where we
found Dead Sea Scrolls, hotels will be
filled with homosexuals,
lesbians doing
and
s.
Having orgies.
Right?
And they're telling me
Israel's God's people, this is God's
land.
Are you sick and on drugs?
Right?
15 hotels, beach complexes, parties, and
a central performance arena, all
operating around the clock.
Alongside the nightlife, Prideland, it's
called Prideland, you believe it?
Will have cultural art complexes.
So, they're going to have artworks
celebrating homosexuality, lesbianism,
right? Transgenderism, but they will
then destroy icons and statues of their
God and savior and judge, Jesus Christ,
and his holy saints and martyrs.
Those
paintings and
icons they'll destroy.
Now, watch how sick this is.
Cultural art complex la- la- relaxation,
scenic areas, and family-friendly areas
with children's activities.
Yeah, so they can educate the children
and prey on them.
Like Epstein, right?
David Wood, apostate prophets,
>> [clears throat]
>> master because Netanyahu,
Israeli government, worked with Epstein
to get dirt on all these people to put
them in their pockets and then to
threaten them, to expose them?
Children, too, huh?
The organizers hope to create a
multi-generation pride city. Pride city.
Not just the party celebrating pride.
"This is not just another festival, it's
the biggest thing we've done here,"
explained Aaron Cohen, main producer, a
Jew, initiator of the festival.
"We chose to grow," Cohen added, "to
take an investment of millions."
Millions from where? Your tax dollars.
Your politicians who are
are part of United States of Israel.
Over 300 billion dollars on top of all
the other billions and the bombs
sent to Israel. This is your money.
The millions come from you.
Who's speaking out against this?
David Wood, who's now being financed by
Barzel?
You disgusting pig. May the Lord deal
with you
and your crew and have mercy on
Avery and Michael. May the Lord have
mercy on them.
They don't know any better. The Lord
Jesus have mercy on them.
And I pray you rebuke you to fear the
Lord and repent. You're a cult leader,
you're sick.
You're worse than Muhammad hijab cuz you
pretend to be a Christian. "This is not
just a pride event. It also aims to
highlight the Dead Sea region as a
permanent destination." Permanent.
They want to make the Dead Sea area
permanent.
The Dead Sea area where you had the
Qumran community, where we found the
Dead Sea Scrolls,
where John the Baptist would have been
intermingling with them because he was
in the wilderness
when the word of God told him, "Now,
leave and go and prepare for Christ."
Permanent destination for LGBT tourists,
emphasizing that pride in Israel extends
beyond the key hub of Tel Aviv.
>> [laughter]
>> Prideland's main stage will host
Adel Scott, Dana International, Ron
Danker,
Shahad Dabur, David Wood, and Ridvan.
Every leader alongside DJs from the
Israeli LGBT community. In fact, here,
guys,
how about we start a GoFundMe
page.
We will pay for David Wood and apostate
prophet first-class tickets to Israel.
Well, they won't need us to pay for it
cuz
their lord and savior,
Sinyahu, will pay for it.
I want them to go there for that entire
week, film,
film live, go live, and film
them preaching the gospel of Jesus
Christ, preaching Leviticus 18 and 20 to
the Jews, reminding them what they're
doing is an abomination,
and it goes against Moses, their great
prophet.
So, they're adding sin upon sin. They
reject Jesus, and they sin against
Moses' law.
You think they'll do that?
You guys think they'll do that?
What do you think, guys?
Ephesians 5:
11, my brother. Ephesians 5:11. I'll
show it to you.
Guys, you think they'll take us up on
it?
May the Lord shut them down in Jesus'
name. Be zealous for your glory, Lord,
and have mercy on us.
Right?
"Prideland does not come to replace Tel
Aviv's traditional pride parade. So,
that's not going to replace it. We're
going to still have pride parade in Tel
Aviv,
but rather to add to the community an
event that is tailored to its
development and is crafted from within
the community,
the community's people," explained
Jonathan Godel,
CEO of Fx Production. "The event comes
at a challenging time for Israel on the
national stage with tourism affected by
the country's security situation." As
they're bombing Lebanon, bombing
Christian villages,
destroying icons of our Lord Jesus and
his saints. You can destroy the image,
you can't destroy the saints. They're
alive, like our sister said. And Jesus
Almighty,
he's patient with you.
But when he comes in his wrath, then you
will tremble like dogs before his feet.
"The event comes at a challenging time
for Israel on the international stage,
tourism affected by the country's
security situation.
The organizers aim to present a message
of openness and acceptance in community.
Ticket and package sales are expected
open soon, will include hotel
accommodation in the area,
daily admission, and premium packages."
And you still think David Wood's a
Christian, huh?
Seriously, do you think that?
You think he's a Christian?
Okay.
He's scum of the earth. He's worse than
the Muslims like Muhammad hijab. Why?
Cuz he masquerades as a Christian, and
he that makes him dangerous cuz there
are idiots who believe him.
He's now using his cult followers
who follow him to finance
his
jihad against those
who call him out. It's all about him.
It's not about Christ.
It's all about him and his cult
followers. If you dare dox them or say
something, I'm coming after you.
Because it's about him,
the egomaniac. It's about him. It's not
about Jesus.
Right?
Anyway, let me just show you one more
thing.
And then we're going to begin.
Okay?